I like to put for the family everybody
just has to eat what mama cooks Koran
mama is in the house now and she's like
well he doesn't really like that you
know I have some Piz za in the
refrigerator my son's like pizza I'm
like wait how do you also learning to
live with her parents again kelly
osbourne when you visit revisit your
parents later on after you move down at
alight and then you come back into the
house I don't mean this disrespectfully
but I don't know if I would used to by
when mom does internet shopping she
takes pictures of her computer screen
with her phone and then sends me the
picture of her computer screen and asks
me to buy it for her when she could just
click it on the computer screen but you
know your cook food we're getting there
that's right Ozzy that's what we had you
for Kelly's actually quarantine at her
parents house so they can shoot
celebrity watch party together just like
Tyra and her mom the Fox show that airs
tonight is giving us a whole new look
inside life at home with some of our
favorite celebs I love watching TV with
my mom and there's one thing that we
love to do which is talk back to this
great what is it like with you guys
watching TV together so if we're
watching something right and he's not
interested he just falls asleep
excuse me mister your favorite movie is
the notebook what you end up crying
thank you didn't go with Miami
the Prince of John was crying at a
Slurpee film didn't go around will
[Music]